[Music]  [Music]  so many people have heard that you can  do horse hoof sounds with coconuts in  this case I actually used horse hoofs I  feel like if you have access to them  it's much better option  the individual elements are created  while watching the action on screen one  at a time and they're recorded into a  digital audio station by a fully reports  something as simple as a body fall can  have multiple elements a dog walking  down the street has its foot stabs in a  collar which kind of move in tandem you  can't rip an arm off without tearing  some skin breaking some bones  [Music]  [Music]  I love Foley because it's creative it's  fun and it's very immediate I like to  live as in the moment as possible and  this is the perfect job for that when an  actor smashes a plate you go get a plate  and you smash the plate  [Music]  you